[Music]
[Music]
we
infer with our modeling and our methods
that um most of the introductions and
and also like the introductions that led
to community spread
uh were derived from cases uh from
europe most of them
uh seem to have happened uh during the
month of february
all the boroughs have similar diversity
of viruses
it speaks only like how connected like
the city
is
[Music]
we are calling this like a precision
surveillance right in the same way that
it's used like precision
uh health it's using the genomic tools
to actually provide this additional
level of resolution right like at the
individual cases
we can also complement the sequencing
information with for example
demographics
where these patients are coming from
right like from which borrows we only
sequence around 10 percent
of the samples that we had here
at the hospital however only from that
small sample size
we were able to capture a little bit
of each bottle
is this virus going to become an endemic
virus in new york
right or are we going to be able to
eradicate it
is it like some areas in the city that
are more affected
than others if coronavirus continues to
circulate and then we get to the winter
we know that's the flu season
when you have two major respiratory
viruses cause circulating right
and how is that going to impact the
whole health system we want to do
more characterizations of the diversity
also in the
in a laboratory setting to understand
better
the impact of the mutations that we're
seeing
finally we also want to keep an eye
right at
what happens when a vaccine is
introduced or any research right like
you end up with more
questions than answers